[Musique]
julie callas sa terre bonjour bonjour
ironie merci d'être sur le plateau de tv
78 pour ce vip que l'on va entièrement
vous consacrez vous être ici car vous
êtes versaillaise vous êtes aussi
libanaise et vous allez nous parler de
différents événements qui vont avoir
lieu prochainement en fait vous êtes la
présidente de neubois dites moi alors
tout d'abord merci de m'avoir invité
facebook et 6 1
je suis donc comme vous avez dit
judiciaire je suis présidente de l'union
de l'uicn 78 à leurs vieux miroirs
l'union libanaise on voit le logo et
c'est l'union libanaise culturelle
mondiale
donc c'est une association non
gouvernementale et qui a accrédité
auprès de l'ecosoc des nations unies et
membre associé du dpi des nations unies
elle a une dimension c'est pas une
association comme les autres c'est une
association vraiment internationale où
nous avons plus de 50
nous sommes implantés dans 50 pays des
cas et nous avons plus de 200 conseils
nationaux de par le monde d'accord ok
donc c'est vraiment mondiale c'est
vraiment rêver à tout à fait alors vous
avez des différentes actions est
apparemment très dynamique qui se passe
tout le temps plein de choses
donc la prochaine qui va arriver ce sera
le 12 octobre
vous allez planter si j'ai bien compris
un du liban au domaine de madame
elisabeth à versailles alors ça vous
l'avez fait ya pas très longtemps déjà
un plaisir tout à fait n'est d'accord
c'est alors pourquoi cet acte à côté moi
pour coiffer tact tout d'abord parce que
le pour nous le cèdent re est quelque
chose de sacré oui c'est notre emblème
national et ils trônent majestueusement
au milieu de notre de notre s'être au
milieu de notre drapeau
oui ces symboles visibles en quoi tout à
fait tout à fait d'aller ben oui et
c'était un cèdre qui est sacré qui a été
cité dans les trois religions
monothéistes a que je parle du judaïsme
et je parle du christianisme et je parle
de l'islam et qui a été utilisé depuis
salomon pour la construction du temple
qui a été vénéré
ok donc c'est un arbre qui rassemble
finalement tout à fait c'est un steak
temps en temps quand on plante un s'être
c'est un événement rassembleur un
événement fédérateur
voilà c'est un symbole de paix nationale
on est là on le plante parce que quand
on est dans un pays d'accueil c'est vrai
que nous sommes dits nationaux notre
pays natal c'est le liban mais notre
pays d'accueil que nous aimons c'est
c'est la france est donc en gage
d'amitié
oui nous offrons ce que nous avons de
plus cher à d'avoir tout à fait nous
avons fait plus sur plantation
c'est-à-dire l'union libanaise
culturelle image là des plantations
justement ces dix là voilà ça c'est avec
le président vienne voilà le président
de l'uicn france monsieur moussa ghana
qui est conseiller municipal a plutôt
avec madame actuellement ce verger vice
président du département et maire de
plaisir et notre vice président et l
5,78
monsieur richard victimes c'était une
très belle cérémonie
nous l'avons fait c'est le 13 avril
c'était une teinte fatidique pour nous
passer c'était le départ de la guerre au
liban le début de la guerre le début de
la guerre au liban de 13 avril 1975 et
donc 25 années trente années par la
suite nous étions en train de planter le
cèdre de maps et on fait d'accord vous
même vous avez vécu au liban jusqu'à
jusqu'à quand alors moi j'ai fait toutes
mes études au liban je suis fils à des
études j'ai fait d'école de traducteurs
et d'interprètes à l'université
saint-joseph d'accord et je suis
traductrice assermentée de formation
mais toute ma vie j'ai travaillé dans
les dents des relations publiques dans
l'événementiel et
nous habitions vu le temps fille de
militaire
nous habitions banques des immeubles qui
était bombardé de plein fouet
donc nos meilleures années était
vraiment dans des abris les abris
souterrains
tout à fait si vos journées et vos nuits
tafer caché pendant des années même par
exemple l'université saint joseph
elles étaient situées sur des lignes de
démarcation c'est à dire bon je n'ai
plus dans notre conscience était là
c'était était malheureusement c'était la
guerre il y avait une partie et une
autre partie et cette ligne
c'était très très dangereux de ses
rentes et ça va durer combien d'années
alors la guerre de 1975 1990 voilà ça
c'est dit votre jeunesse
tout à fait et puis alors avec charles
avec mon mari nous avons décidé de
donner une nouvelle chance à nos enfants
on a dit on veut pas faire subir à nos
enfants ce que nous nous avons subi
d'accord et puis la france où sont
passés sous protectorat français ça
s'est magnifiquement passé nous sommes
très proches de la france et par nos
costumes et parlons valeur et qu'est ce
qu'il ya de mieux que de venir en france
et alors vous êtes nombreux à versailles
par exemple ou dans les yvelines et
beaucoup de familles libanaises d'un
personnage peut dire quand même que nous
sommes plus de 70 familles je pars ami
louis ils sont surtout centrées rocher
n'est d'accord il ya également à saint
cyr il ya également à plaisir à voisins
le bretonneux amont tiny wings octobre
l'homme est importante tout à fait ok
donc ce fameux revenons à notre 12
octobre donc il y aura la plantation que
ce cèdre qui sera en présence de
l'ambassadeur du gisement vous m'avez
dit tout à fait y avait des gens très
importants
c'est à dire que notre ambassadeur c'est
lui qui représente le liban et c'est en
france il assuré donc nous voulions
mettre cette plantation ce sens où sont
nos m'attends à tout à fait et puis
certainement avec le président du
département des yvelines monsieur pierre
bédier qui s'avère aussi que cela aussi
et c'est ça s'est tellement passé vite
c'est lors d'un meeting électoral
j'aborde monsieur bédié en lui disant il
ya un plan et il ya un cèdre qui
manquent à versailles
soit on le plan sera au domaine de
madame elisabeth affaire voilà et il est
entouré d'une excellente équipe est
vraiment je tiens à les remercier pour
leur patience et leur et leur aide
eh ben ça c'est fait alors après il va
se passer un autre événement qui sera
qui aura lieu en novembre on sait pas
trop à quel jour exactement mais vous
m'avez dit plus tôt fin novembre vous
organisez une vente de produits libanais
au profit des chrétiens du liban tout
qui sont donc restés là bas ça c'est une
autre association association mission
solidarité liban d'accueil rasé à
versailles et dont la présidente est
caroline de ray ban alors en quoi
consiste cette action voilà ça c'est des
nous faisons des micro projets d'accord
que nous alimentons entre autres nous
avons choisi d'aider les chrétiens du
liban les oléiculteurs d'accord qu'il
puisse rester sur leurs terres est-ce
qu'ils sont menacés de toute expulsion
était non c'est à dire que la région au
sud est un petit peu stratégiquement
parlant sensible on voit là tout à fait
face qu'ils ont quoi comme frontières
excusez moi je suis nul en géographie
mal et on à israël oui en assyrie david
akers chose voilà on est assis sur une
poudrière d'accord donc ils produisent
leur leur huile oui nous les avons aidés
à monter leur huile riz ils produisent
leurs 8 et au moins de novembre nous
nous importons 2000 bouteilles d'huile
d'accord qui devrait être vendue à leers
au fil du temps vendu tous les années à
ala à l'église de notre challenger et
versailles tout à fait ok ça on le
redira est absolument je vous redire
donc cet argent permet à ces
cultivateurs de rester ce réseau là sur
place et de garder leurs terres parce
que juste pour vous dire un petit point
véronique en quelques en quelques mots
vite fait c'est à dire que le liban
il est de 10 mille quatre cent cinquante
kilomètres carrés
d'accord c'est à dire un petit peu le
département de la gérante chez de la
gironde chez vos peu le département de
le sud
comment s'appelle l'île de la corse
d'accord avec être millions d'habitants
être millions d'habitants mais nous
avons plus de 12 millions de libanais à
l'étranger
c'est ça je reviens à l'union libanaise
culturelle mondiale
le but de cette union de par le monde
c'est vraiment avoir un contact direct
avec cette diaspora avec tous les
libanais mais en même temps avec leur
pays d'accueil
d'accord alors si on veut mieux vous
connaître vous les libanais de
l'étranger
on peut aussi vous retrouvez au journée
mondiale du liban le sérieux en avouant
même et avait fait en mai et ça a lieu
mairie du quatrième à paris je vois que
vous êtes les informer sur l âge de
voter tout à l'heure dite mois julie
alors d'ores-et-déjà la sauver le monde
tout à fait d'ores-et-déjà je vous
invite dès maintenant à c'est un
événement phare de l'union libanaise
culturelle est ici en france les
journées du liban à paris oui cette
année ça va être notre sixième édition
d'accord donc en quoi consiste cette un
collectif d'une cinquantaine
d'associations franco libanaise et nous
les disposons c'est la mairie du ivème
qui nous offre la halle des blancs
manteaux et que nous nous les disposons
en forme de petit petit kiosque
je dirais
on verra avec un programme je suis
chargé de la programmation entre autres
avec un programme festif mais également
culturel c'est-à-dire un viêt les gens
toute la semaine travail et là ils sont
besoin d'un petit peu de se divertir et
puis aussi de s'informer parce qu'on
connaît pas tout tout ce que vous allez
nous montrer enfin je pense que c'est
vraiment la découverte du liban à
travers ses nombreuses associations il y
avait tout ce qui se passe c'est tous
les partenariats qu'on peut
éventuellement mettre en place ou enfin
je pense qu'il ya plein de choses à
découvrir
tout à fait on parle du culinaire de la
gastronomie on parle également de la
philatélie on parle également du
tourisme
alors on m'avait dit philatélie parce
qu'il va y avoir un timbre d'éditer au
moment de la plantation de ce sel c'est
à dire que je le montre comme ça c'est
une amitié franco libanaise et c'est
l'association de l'eba qui est présidée
par eliane web et qui nous émeut à la
voile écran voilà tout à fait pas
pouvoir la voir à partir de quand c'est
ce thème là il sera offert au président
bédié est également je tenais à dire que
c'est monsieur le préfet qui va être
également pré présent et que on va lui
offrir
c'est un terreau prenable par
l'association débat donc écouté et on a
des milliards de choses à dire déjà jugé
qu elle a cet air merci beaucoup d'être
venu sur le plateau pour nous donner
envie de découvrir le liban en attendant
dans les yvelines
et puis on ira admirer ce cèdre au
domaine de madame elisabeth ii qui
poussent vite ça va avec la pluie la
veille bien nous l'avons acheté il avait
2 m il ya déjà deux médailles
vous faites les choses en grand tout à
fait c'est via pas écouté bravo merci
et puis très vite et puis on oublie pas
les journées du vivant au my name et
bientôt au moins là le 22 et 23 novembre
lu le livre avec la mairie depuis
également nous faisons les journées du
liban parce que c'est l'indépendance du
liban que nous fêtons le 22 novembre
pleines festivités en perspective alors
vous êtes invités vous êtes la bienvenue
est d'accord
merci beaucoup à vous et à très vite
julie j'aurais souhaité juste terminée
par un parent citations sur 2,7 vous
permettra avec désirs allez-y alors
c'est en 1920 un des textes de la
proclamation du grand liban déclare un
cèdre toujours vert c'est un peuple
toujours jeune en dépit d'un passé cruel
quoique opprimés jamais copie le cèdre
et son signe de ralliement par l'union
il brisera toutes les attaques
c'est à dire que nous sommes nous avons
de l'espoir comme se sert de notre pays
bon eh ben écoutez bravo merci merci
aviator et à bientôt
[Musique]